how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
mcu and today it looks like we have a
new character coming to the mcu
in the hawkeye series and it looks like
this character could reveal somewhat of
a story plot for the hawkeye series and
possibly have a pretty big connection to
the x-men
in the mcu with all of the marvel phase
4 movies
and shows coming out and being in
production currently we've had a lot of
evidence suggesting that the mutants
and x-men will be coming to the mcu
sooner than we thought
in fact it looks like we could be seeing
the mutants in the mcu as early on as
the black widow film or the falcon and
the winter soldier series but let's
break down how
professor xavier's school for gifted
youngsters could be in the background of
marvel's phase 4
and how it could have been in the
background of the mcu's infinity saga
this entire time
if you love marvel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
videos and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a cyclops
funko pop to subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below so so far in each project for
phase four
black widow falcon in the winter soldier
one division etc it looks like each
project is going to introduce
a mutant or mutants to the mcu now
eventually
this will lead up to many mutants
existing in the mcu and eventually the
x-men will be formed
now based off of everything that we know
from the comics and the story of the
x-men from the comics the x-men will
most likely be formed by professor x in
the mcu
there is a chance that marvel could
switch that but it's not likely which
leads us to professor xavier's school
for gifted youngsters
as the x-men get introduced in the mcu
will undoubtedly see professor xavier
school show up he'll try to recruit and
help the younger mutants and of course
the older mutants will be teachers at
the school
and yesterday we got confirmation that a
new character is coming to the hawkeye
series who just so happens to be
a gifted youngster yesterday the
illuminati.com
reported that marvel studios right now
currently is casting for the role of
echo for the upcoming hawkeye series now
this is pretty exciting because we'll be
getting the first depth character in the
mcu
in fact the casting call reads as
follows deaf
native american first nations indigenous
and or latinx independent athletic
and bright and it also says that the
audition scenes
dialogue is also set to be signed in
american sign language so this is really
cool news but here's the connection
echo has quite an interesting origin
story echo's real name is maya
and maya's father was willy crazy horse
lincoln and he was killed
by kingpin but something really weird
happened as he died
as he was dying he actually asked
kingpin to raise his daughter and
kingpin
would go on to raise her as if she was
his own child
now maya is originally believed to be
mentally disabled by kingpin so he sends
her to
a school for people with learning
disabilities however they would go on to
realize that she's not actually mentally
disabled but she's rather
gifted she is then sent to a school for
prodigies
now eventually maya through daredevil
would go on to realize
that kingpin was actually the one that
killed her father and after practically
taking down kingpin she runs away and
then eventually would come back to the
united states
she would go on to join the new avengers
as a version of
ronan the same ronin that hawkeye had
became in the past now obviously we know
that marvel studios doesn't do an
adaptation of a comic
shot for shot in fact sometimes they
don't even take stories from comics but
rather just
characters and put them in new stories
which is great because if they just did
the stories from the comics we'd know
everything that would happen
but maya is going to be a youngster that
is gifted and she's not going to have
any parents
and currently right now with the
avengers and how the mcu is set up right
now
there's nothing or no one really there
to take her in and that is where i
believe professor xavier's school will
come in
we know the mutants are coming and
whether or not this is formed from wanda
creating different realities and somehow
creating the mutants or whether the blip
created mutants or not it's coming and
it's going to be a refuge for
new young mutants and i think it's going
to play a pretty pivotal role
in the mcu in introducing the mutants
and down the road
the x-men however she is going to pop up
in the hawkeye series first and the fact
that ekko is a deaf character in the
fact that the actress that's going to be
playing her needs to know american sign
language
points to the story of hawkeye losing
his hearing now we've had rumors of this
in the past before
marvel studios adapting the story arc in
which hawkeye loses his hearing
and the fact that ekko a deaf character
is being cast for the hawkeye series
is further evidence that we could be
getting the story now hawkeye is already
going to be training kate bishop who is
also pretty young which means that by
the end of the hawkeye series he's going
to be taking care of two
young new superheroes but we know that
they won't stay with him so from here
kate bishop will most likely go on to
join the new avengers and then ekko
would go on to go to professor xavier's
school
and from there i think we're actually
going to see a lot of other mutants that
will pop
up during phase 4. now in the beginning
there may not be enough for an entire
school we may actually see
charles xavier start the school but by
the end of phase 4 or phase 5 the school
could be established and the x-men could
be established as well
so let me know what you think about this
do you think the x-men and mutants have
been lurking in the background
of the mcu this entire time or do you
think that somehow the snap caused
mutants to exist or there will be some
other way but regardless these
new mutants are going to need some help
and that's where professor xavier school
comes in
so let me know what you think about this
in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof